jurors will begin their fifth hour of
deliberations in the Bill Cosby sexual
assault trial this morning they asked
about Cosby's 2005 deposition last night
jurors wanted to re-examine the section
where Cosby admitted to giving pills to
accuse her andrea constand cosby is
charged with three counts of aggravated
indecent assault he is now 79 years old
and if convicted he could face up to ten
years in prison
Jericka Duncan is outside the courthouse
in Norristown Pennsylvania
Jericka good morning good morning the
jurors ordered takeout here to the
courthouse and deliberated until about
9:30 last night now they were left
considering those closing arguments that
revisited themes that we've heard
throughout the trial for example the
defense said that the relationship
between andrea constand and Bill Cosby
was romantic while the prosecution
implored jurors to look at this case as
one about a woman who was taken
advantage of and unable to consent bald
eagle
Bill Cosby was upbeat as he walked out
of court late Monday night after jurors
deliberated for four hours earlier that
day Cosby's wife Camille arrived in
court for the first time she was calm
and appeared to smile as the defense
spent nearly two hours making their
closing arguments the defense told
jurors that Cosby had danced outside his
marriage and that his wife deserved
better
but that Cosby didn't commit a crime mr.
Cosby is very competent he's covered in
his legal team this is the place where
you come and get the truth andrea
constand watched from the front row of
the courtroom
the prosecution spoke last they told
jurors Constance spent a lot more time
trying to forget about the alleged
assault rather than trying to remember
what Cosby did to her last week constant
testified Cosby drugged her with pills
and sexually assaulted her at his
philadelphia area home in 2004 while the
prosecution called 12 witnesses the
defense presented only one a detective
who interviewed both Cosby and constand
in 2005 his testimony lasted six minutes
throughout the trial Cosby's teen tried
to weaken constants version of events
and said constant old a quote stone cold
live when she told investigators she
didn't contact Cosby after the alleged
assault
we knew that Andrea constants testimony
would be a key factor in this case how
well did she do I thought she provided a
very coherent believable version of
events the problems that the prosecution
has is that there are a lot of
inconsistencies and those calls after
the event
resonate with some jurors the jury is
expected back in court later this
morning and this trial is moving faster
than anticipated the judge told the
jurors they could expect to be here at
least two weeks Nora
all right drinka Duncan thank you